Oh God he's strong but not strong enough
[Applause]
you feel that that's the sound of waves
about to move you a sub seafood you know
this is the game that will define your
existence I can't believe I have not
played this game before tell us your
background and my a macro or perhaps
sardine salmon or spiny lobster or even
better
shrimp its fate is to crawl across
ground however its shell very hard spiny
lobster it is Oh God
die fateful starfish whatever you are a
spiny lobster joins an army excellent
humming missiles you can have allies
attack with you or act as bait got it
alright music this is me moving quickly
apparently to this game I move so fast I
can finally swim my swimming like a
human it's making me uncomfortable
alright there's another reef over here
we will conquer the sea and annihilate
all mackerel swim swimming engage this
game is a fever dream oh god here we go
Red Frog crab oh my god my immortal
enemy I must destroy him defeat him
harming myself
arrow form oh that was it okay cool
alright let's scan for and more reefs
what do we got we got one over here
oh god it's on land can I enter land
lobster can enter land of course
god it's so uncomfortable this game you
know it's Japanese developers they're
the only ones capable of creating
something so awful and amazing at the
same time oh god what is that lock on
target lionfish kill
oh god no no I didn't know I haven't
made a mistake swim swim lobster decoy
ah he's shooting lasers he's crazy
good
I should not have engaged for the
lionfish lesson learned we will have to
develop and grow stronger first I
understand the age of the anthropods
will rise yeah yeah yeah we can kill
stinky prawns dead to me dead to me die
die a death oh god they're strong decoy
engage decoy oh god they got decoys as
well sir there's too many of them
welcome target there's a chance more
humming missiles I never been this
engaged in the battle in my entire life
decoy engage decoy no this is just like
real life I think I can beat people up
and in reality now I'm I'm useless will
conquer the bottom of the ocean first
we're getting stronger every day
there's king crab over there but they
are damaged so maybe there is chance
lock on target oh my god we're doing
damage on them
king crab kill them kill the king crab
long leg that can go spiny lobster
they're almost down there is hope come
on come on come on come on oh god
they're shooting back oh that's bad how
is it still alive Jesus Christ
are you kidding me we can defeat the
sardines right there we go it begins oh
that was easy
nice
Jesus Christ oh my god we killed a yes
the land we control the land another one
the age of anthropods did I did I eat
got it we got it yes
ah yes power unlimited power the reef is
ours the spiny sculpture belongs to the
lobster
[Music]
yes eat [ __ ] hermit crabs one-armed
throw pod to rule them home I hope God
I'm getting seasick literally what's
happening
this one is toughest dude yes we can
enter the refrigerator we've conquered
the East we're getting stronger but this
is just the beginning
spiny lobsters I gotta destroy these
Fletcher's
[Music]
I think I suck one I've sunk one humming
miss Stiles that's what I was supposed
to use two down one more to go
yes yes it's not a shark I don't know
why I'm surprised to see a shark out of
all things in this game first we
conquered the sea then we conquer the
land come on follow me
oh Jesus Lord what is that anthropods we
answer to no seal and robots waiting for
the right time to strike
Wow wait I can become the [ __ ] I what oh
my god
I thought I was doomed to be a lobster
my whole life no no oh there's the
stingrays let's drop torpedoes never
mind we're coming down cold we're now a
submarine for no reason at all Jesus
Christ this thing is so [ __ ] slow be
smart class Oh God no box I'm sorry
Oh No I will destroy them don't worry
that will set me free why is there bass
mark in this game
I can't even penetrate [ __ ] mark Jesus
Christ the damage retreat No we'll win a
lobster or a Nazi German warship he
attacks from above no one expects that
giant lobster die from above no god damn
Bismarck
[Music]
[Music]
wait what do we defeat Bismarck we
defeated Bismarck
how I can make myself into a ball
everyone we attack from the skies oh my
god it works this is so dumb
attack from above yeah but yeah I've
seen this game before I just saw
critical played recently and I thought
how I forgot about this game so good I'm
so invested in this game there you are
cowards cowards of the seas dan they'd
kill me fast Jesus what on God's earth
is that I'm not sure she should even ask
you the great one
oh yes the king cramps we attack from
the surface oh god the crabs can also go
in surface this is a major oversight
we're gonna thing gage yes what's the
other one
oh god he's strong but not strong enough
Reed we will breed more of them we will
breed them stronger we shall become oh
my god stingrays they must be powerful
what they have lasers that's so unfair
come on come on come on come on come on
big uh we're going down Lobster going
down Oh the age of anthropods is over
the time for the very ugly fishes has
come I think I figured the game out more
or less
Oh God oh god no don't ever do that
again
we're in Antarctica blast our way
through
oh yeah it's not fish it started when
they walked on lion this is actually a
history lesson if you packed in the
video game I'm finishing this game I
don't know I don't know what it takes
but I will do it
the anthropods will rise gamers rise up
no anthropods there's some penguins over
there who will win in battle and throw
pod or penguin we're about to find out
come on enter punch he's got to go all
in
you've got it all in stop penguin
anthropods anthropods Oh smack him smack
him that's how it's done
anthropods and robots anthropods roast
this ocean loulou's oh and that's how
it's done we're in space
Wow incredible anthropods have been
proven to be the strongest race we did
it gamers undefeated undisputed
grenadiers fishing game I have ever
played thank you guys for watching smash
like subscribe Hado